hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to we've
all come across that film those either
good or okay but then the ending ruins
everything from into darkness to war of
the worlds' - yeah every single air man
movie fan thing can often have a talent
for taking several hours of our lives
that were enjoyable and suddenly making
you feel like they were wasted but why
if two-thirds of the movie are good
sometimes even more than that why do we
get so upset when a small percentage is
bad if we have a meal that's mostly good
but might have a spice we don't like we
don't get too angry if we look at a
painting that moves us but might have
one stroke that's a little off we don't
dismiss the whole thing as garbage so
why does the ending have such an impact
on us why can it ruin what was for the
most part perfectly fine without getting
too much into spoiler territory we
should probably talk about some of the
films that have what many consider awful
endings without actually giving the
endings away some of the more notable
ones as I mentioned before are into
darkness and war the worlds but other
ones a lot of people bring up recently
or I am Legend amazing spider-man 2 the
number 23 ninth gate and now you see me
all of them have audiences going on and
on about how they would have liked the
film if it hadn't been for the last few
minutes I'm actually a firm believer
that x-men 3 would have been that bad a
film or at least on par with the others
if the ending actually went somewhere
important instead of just you know
sucked a lot of characters are killed
off but if it led to somewhere
meaningful people probably would have
accepted it and acknowledged a lot more
of the cooler scenes arguably some of
the cool is out of the previous x-men
films a good example of doing that right
actually comes from another x-men film
in a lot of ways Days of Future past
actually does what x-men 3 did it kills
off a lot of characters from the
previous film changes timelines from the
comic and puts characters in roles very
different from their original intention
but it works in Days of Future past
because it amounted to something
something important something huge
because of this people remember even
more the cool visuals and action
sequences where x-men 3's are overlooked
forgotten even this cleanslate still had
kill see grammar back arguably the best
beast so even the sequel trying to wreak
on this movie had to acknowledge there
are some things that were really good so
even if a movie throws in a lot of cool
stuff oftentimes it just comes down to
what do you have to say there's an
alternate ending on the thank you for
smoking DVD that actually destroys
everything the film had been building on
this ending would have transformed it
from one of the greatest comedies ever
written to meeting absolute dick why
because the film was about going all the
way finally picking an ethical side and
sticking to it without tap-dancing it's
like watching all of Schindler's List
and at the very end somebody just says
maybe Hiller was right and they roll the
credits everything would have been
nothing and all from just one line
spielberg obviously knew how to end this
movie but that hasn't always been the
case with him from War of the Worlds to
lost world to Minority Report to AI to
even the movie that invented the
blockbuster jaws yeah they brilliantly
kept the shark a secret building up what
he looks like but then when they
actually showed more and more of him a
lot of people weren't impressed the more
they revealed shark still looks fake but
the interesting thing about spielberg is
half the time he's pigeon held into
these endings where the world's for
example is technically how the book ends
but the other incarnations knew to make
a bigger deal out of it this one forgets
to have a climax which is closer to the
book but not the best for a movie ai is
known as one of his worse endings but he
did it as a dedication to his friend
Stanley Kubrick who despite every writer
telling Stanley that the ending sucked
still wanted it that way before he died
so Spielberg did his best honor his
wishes who would have thought being too
faithful and understanding could work
against a film nevertheless most of
these movies were still hits despite
them leaving people scratching their
heads at the endings in fact for all the
films we bring up they have endings that
ruin the movie sometimes a bad ending
doesn't even make a dent take Superman
for example arguably the stupidest
cop-out ending ever yet people still see
this as the best Superman film because
everything else was so good even the
emotion before the lame ending was
genuinely powerful
returned the king practically held us
hostage for the number of endings it had
but everything else was so huge and well
done and it was wrapping up three very
long movies that we allowed our asses
going numb for these sometimes awkward
moments hmmm that's still creepy people
didn't like the Ewoks or Vader's reveal
and return the Jedi but they still
thought to close things out well enough
and even all the Iron Man movies with
their painfully botched villains in each
film still managed to be spectacular at
the box office so what did these films
do right to excuse the bad endings that
these films didn't well maybe they got
the spirit down all the Iron Man movies
have had bad final acts but it's still
Robert Downey jr. 'he's incredible
charisma at the center and the
faultiness of his character that drew us
to like them in the first place that is
one of the elements that's always kept
in check you can say the same thing
about Superman
or Star Wars or lower the Rings even
though they get the final part wrong it
still fell it was in the same vein of
what made a charming and likable to
begin with the ending of AI is not the
same feel as they opening the ending of
into darkness is an immediate disconnect
from the rest of the film but this isn't
that surprising seeing how a lot of bad
endings nowadays come from a very
similar place the twist years ago when
The Sixth Sense came out everyone was so
blown away by the surprise ending that
they had to go back and see it again
thus people would go tell their friends
and then they would have to go see it
twice so not only were a ton of people
going to see a movie they were going to
see it two times suddenly a huge hit
didn't need to have a lot of money and
needed a reason for you to come back and
watch it all over again so tons of
movies start to throw in twists even if
they didn't require them at all Dark
Knight Rises remember me Last Exorcism
secret window there's too many to count
even the guy that started this crash
Shyamalan couldn't keep up with
constantly forcing them into his stories
and his films began to suck so movies
that might have been ok are passable
were suddenly destroyed or made worse by
shoving in an unneeded element that
ruins the way not only that
look at the ending but the way you look
at the entire film oh that dumb surprise
at the end is what's supposed to be
going on throughout the entire story no
that just makes the whole entire story
Lightman so okay if an ending can ruin a
film is it possible and ending can save
a film it's no secret I'm not a fan of
Jurassic world but it's hard not to tell
somebody to go see it based on that
kick-ass climax especially fans of the
other movies usual suspects would
approach just been an okay crime
thriller but the ending turns it into a
lot of people's favorite movie
well the most interesting cases of this
is the straight story this film is
purposefully relentless in how slow and
dull it is the majority of the time it's
practically unbearable but by the time
the ending shows up suddenly everything
is made clear why it was so slow and
dull and it makes everything that you
went through suddenly seemed
phenomenally important the whole entire
movie suddenly changes from bad to kind
of brilliant so for some films the
ending is everything but for others it
barely makes a dent how is that possible
well the important thing to realize
especially focus-group suits is that
while filmmaking is very technical and
precise film watching isn't the
experience in viewing a movie isn't
measurements or mathematics as much as
many executives wish it was it's
entirely emotional you want to make a
connection with these characters feel
like you're in their spot and discover
something important or interesting with
them they seem real when this happens
and just like real people in your life
they can piss you off and leave you
angry everyone has a friend that you
love but can sometimes push you a little
too far many friendships have been
broken because they were pushed beyond
what they thought was trustworthy movies
in a strange way are a form of trust
you're taking a gamble spending hours of
your time and money on something
declaring it's going to make a
connection with you if the connection is
bad then the whole movie is bad but if
the connection is good but then suddenly
can't deliver in its most important
moment we feel like that trust has been
betrayed
sometimes that's even worse than a movie
that's bad all the way through we
identified with you movie
we thought you got us you took us to an
emotional place we didn't know existed
and now you throw something at us that
doesn't seem like you at all what
happened I thought you were cool much
like a friendship all the wonderful
moments you spent together can be easily
forgotten because of one terrible choice
that's why so many entertainers use the
phrase always leave them wanting more
because it's the last emotion they
usually remember now does that make it
right that we should dismiss all the
good stuff that they gave us well it
depends on the viewer again like a
person it's all about the emotional
connection you have I can overlook the
lame ending of Last Exorcism but a lot
of folks can't I think the ending of
into darkness ruins everything but some
people don't mind everybody is going to
have a different acceptability of what's
fulfilling and what weaves you lacking
our memories especially tend to put the
most value in the last major thing we
went through even though many other
major things might have happened so can
an ending ruin a film absolutely now
there's good reasons why but that
doesn't mean every film works that way a
movie can have a bad ending but maybe it
wasn't bad enough to overshadow the good
and that thing can even change the way
you look at everything teaching you that
sometimes it really is important to stay
and hear everything someone has to say
it depends on the person and depends on
the movie but one thing's for sure a
movie is never truly over until it's
over the only thing that matters
is the ending anyway what fun is it to
talk about movie that only has a bad
ending it's time to return to the movies
that suck all the way through fine at
least this time I don't have to review
it with a whiny obnoxious pain in the
edges whom out you know he's here what
the hell I had a cool entrance planned
it was a close-up clearly you were gonna
be in the next shot well at least it's
only the two of us doing the review yeah
just view me and is it mirrors that
light looking a little suspicious
no not
[Music]
you
hey Duke Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing Red
Rover org founded in 1987 the mission of
Red Rover is to bring animals out of
crisis and strengthen the bond between
people and animals for emergencies
sheltering disaster relief services
financial assistance and education Red
Rover accomplishes its mission by
engaging volunteers and supporters
collaborating with others and maximizing
the use of online technology they are
about engagement not only with each
other but also side-by-side with animal
professionals animal groups local
officials law enforcement media and
schools you see these little animals you
can't help but say how can I help them
how can I make them the best that they
can be well if you go to their site or
their YouTube channel you can see
they're not only helping these animals
but they're helping a lot of people too
this is a wonderful organization
definitely worth checking out so
definitely go take a look and see how
you can lend a paw
[Music]
you